اهلا بكم مشاهدينا العربيه ما زالت مستمره
في هذه التغطيه منذ لحظه وقوع هذا الزلزال
في تركيا وايضا في سوريا اليوم قرابه 37
الف قتيل حتى الان هذا العدد مرجح
للارتفاع اكثر مع استمرار عمليات رفع
الانقاض في تركيا ومحاولات رفعها حقيقه في
سوريا بسبب ضعف الامكانيات هناك مع الفارق
الكبير بين عمليات الانقاذ والمساعدات
الانسانيه التي وصلت تركيا ونظيرتها في
سوريا بدا السوريون في جمع مساعدات
للمناطق المنكوبه علها تساعد من حلفهم
الحظ في النجاه نتابع
[موسيقى]
انا نازح مغيب من اربع سنوات
نهدد البناي انجرح واحد من عندي من
الاولاد
الجرحى معبينا شوارع الشهداء المشافعت
دمارك كتير بنايات لبينا نداء انه في مخيم
ايواء لانه اخواننا كثيرين وعم نعمل بقدر
الله عليه وسبحان الله انه الجو برد مع كل
هالبرد النداء واخواننا انا نازح بحس
بموعات راح بيته ما ظل عنده ماوى يعني لله
الامر الحمد لله وين هلا عم نسمع يعني
نلبي اخواتنا ان شاء الله وبتمنى من كل
واحد يعني قادر على العمل يعني يذهب بشكل
تطوعي
ويساعد اخواتنا
حجاره متراكمه شكلت كوابيس متلاحقه لسبعه
ايام لكنها اسوار اخفت وراءها مخاوف اكبر
تتمثل بطبيعه الخطوه التاليه
السوريون واتراك وظبوا على انتظار مؤلم
رغم فقدان الامل واخرون بداوا لملمه ماسي
الكارثه والخروج من مرحله الانكار لا
منازل لا اعمال لا مقتنياتنا والاقصى
افراد عائله اقل
معظم مجري ما كانوا عملي كل شيء دمر صحوه
من هول الفاجعه اثارت مخاوف مئات الالاف
من التجمد بردا في العراء درجات حراره
شديده الانخفاض لا ترضعها خيم قماشيه او
ثياب خفيفه كما لا تحمي اطفالا من نزله
برد مسلمه الجو بارد وسنتجمد هنا حتى
الموت اذا جلسنا داخل الخيمه فسوف نتجمد
ياتي ذلك وسط تحذيرات متزايده من كارثه
ثانيه اكثر ضررا من سابقتها تنبع من تاخر
وصول فرق الطوارئ والمساعدات لملايين
المشردين فالالاف ينامون في سياراتهم قرب
الانقاض
كثر كانوا في العراء بظروف متدهوره ومروعه
مع صعوبه كبيره في الوصول للوقود والمياه
والكهرباء وامدادات الاتصالات
منازل مؤقته او فنادق خطه الحكومه التركيه
لاواء الاشخاص الذين دمرت منازلهم او من
يخافون العوده لابنيه صامده بشقوقها
ومهدده بالسقوط
فالرئيس التركي تعهد بعدم السماح ببقاء
المواطنين في الشارع واعاده بناء مئات
الالاف من المباني بسرعه وان كانت تعهدات
بعيده المنال على حد وصف الكثيرين لكن حتى
هكذا وعوده لم تدس عتبه السوريين اكثر من
خمسه ملايين شخص يضافون الى اعداد مماثله
بعثرتهم الحرب خلال السنوات الاثنتي عشره
الماضيه هؤلاء سيتشاركون نقص المعونات
وظروف السكن الصعبه وبروده الطقس
وفي وقت يتواصل تمشيط اكوام الانقاذ
الشاهقه بحثا عن نفس او صوت يطفئ قلوبنا
ترتجف حسره وبردا يفضل ناجون العوده
لمنازلهم المتضرره بشكل بالغ لحفظ كرامه
اب لا يريد لاطفاله امراضا او امراه
انهكها موت معيل
من بلده حارم ينضم اليها الصحفي مسلم
السيد عيسى مسلم اهلا بك اليوم كيف تبدو
الاوضاع اليوم في حارم في هذا اليوم
الثامن ندخل هذا اليوم الثامن بعد هذا
الزلزال وطبعا الاوضاع الماساويه في شمال
غرب سوريا
نعم مساء الخير حقيقه انا لتوضيح في معبر
باب الهوى على الحدود السوريه التركيه هذا
المعبر الذي بدا اليوم يستقبل
وتحسن بشكل جيد لاستقبال المساعدات
الامميه وايضا المساعدات المتعلقه
بالحكومات العربيه وغيرها التي وصلت الى
اقرب قبل ان نتحدث عن معبر باب الهوى يعني
بما انه الان انتقلت الى معبر باب الهوى
ولكن هل يمكن ان تطلعنا اليوم كيف كان
الوضع مثلا في حارم وفي
المناطق الاخرى حيث
يعني طبعا اعمال الانقاض هل ما زالت
مستمره فيها رفع الانقاذ ما هو الوضع قبل
ان ننتقل الى هذا المعبر ونتحدث عن
المساعدات
نعم الواقع حتى اليوم يعني بدا قبل يوم
امس عمليات
الانقاذ من المرحله الثانيه عفوا رفع
الانقاذ من المرحله الثانيه حيث قالت فرق
الدفاع المدني انها ستستغرق ايام طويله
لرفع كامل انقاذ المدن المدمره والاحياء
المدمره خاصه في مده بلدتي حارم وجنديرس
التي شهدت ضررا كبيرا وبالغا نتحدث عن
عشرات الابنيه الطابقيه دمرت وحتى اللحظه
هناك مئات المفقودين تحت هذه المباني بعد
ان اشارت فرق الدفاع المدني وايضا مديريه
الصحه هنا في الشمال السوري الى انه لا
وجود لاي مؤشرات لوجود احياء تحت انقاذ
هذه المباني وهل هناك اليوم من احصائيه من
عدد الجثث التي تم انتشالها اقله خلال 24
ساعه في هذه المناطق
نعم ما اثبت حتى اللحظه هو انتشال 55 جثه
اضافيه تضاف الى
2165 قتيلا قضوا تحت انقاذ منازلهم هذا
الرقم طبعا هو مرجح للزياده والرقم اصلا
بحسب الدفاع المدني انه ليس دقيق لان هناك
المئات من المفقودين لا زالوا تحت انقاذ
المباني وغالب الظن بحسب الدفاع المدني
انهم قدوا تحت هذه المباني وبالتالي فرق
الدفاع المدني بدات بالعمل على مراحل
طويله لرفع الكتل والتلال التي جمعت من
ركام المباني من الطوابق العلويه
ترحيلا لها خارج المدن ثم العوده الى
البحث عن جثث المفقودين تحت المباني مسلم
اذا اردنا الان ان نتحدث عن معبر باب
الهواء كونك هناك كانت هناك انباء تحدثت
بان هناك وقفات احتجاجيه
ترفض مثلا دخول مساعدات اتيه من مناطق
النظام هل هذا الامر على الارض صحيح هل هو
دقيق ماذا لدينا من تفاصيل حول ذلك
نعم بالطبع يعني هنا نفذ اليوم ناشطون
متواجدون في محافظه ادلب وعموم مناطق
الشمال السوري بعض الوقفات التي نددت وقال
فيها الناشطون انهم لا يريدون تلقي
مساعدات من النظام الذي هو بالاصل قام
بتهجيرهم من قرى ومدن وبلدات من عموم
مناطق سوريا عموم الذين يتواجدون هنا في
هذه المناطق نحن نتحدث عن اثنين فاصله
ثمانيه مليون شخص متواجدون في المدن
والمخيمات هم من النازحين والمهجرين الى
شمال السوري وبالتالي هم اكثرهم من
المتضررين بشكل مباشر من النظام يبدو انهم
اوضحوا بشكل مباشر انهم لا يريدون تلقي اي
مساعدات ولا يثقون بوصول هذه المساعدات
اليهم بشكل مباشر وان النظام يحاول ربما
الاستفاده من الموضوع من النواحي غيرها
لكن بشكل عام
ما وصل حتى اللحظه من عبر الحدود هو اكثر
من 75 شاحنه من المساعدات الامميه
المتنوعه وصلت الى هذه المناطق عبر ثلاث
معابر وهي معبر باب الهوى ومعبر باب
السلامه وايضا معبر هو عفرين والمسمى
بمعبر الحمام هذه المساعدات توزعت بين
المساعدات التابعه للامم المتحده من
المساعدات السعوديه والمساعدات القطريه
والكويتيه وغيرها المساعدات بدات قبل يعني
مع صباح اليوم بالتوزيع واقامه المؤسسات
الانسانيه المحليه بتوزيعها على
المستفيدين لكن بشكل تدريجي لا يتوافق
ربما مع حجم الكارثه بسبب حاله تعيشها
المنطقه نتحدث عن اكثر من 30 الف عائله هم
في مراكز الايواء هل هناك من وقت محدد تمر
فيه هذه الشاحنات يعني هل تتوقف مثلا
اثناء الليل وفقد خلال النهار تعبر هذه
الشاحنات ام حتى خلال الليل حركه هذه
الشاحنات ما زالت مستمره يعني نحن لحظنا
توقف عبور هذه الشاحنات قبل ثلاث ساعات
تقريبا من الان كان دخول اخر شاحنه
للمساعدات الامميه وايضا المساعدات
الحكوميه وكان هناك اخر وفي دخل الى
المنطقه وبالتالي هي يبدو انها تعمل
بالشفتات فقط النهاريه من الطرف لاننا
نعلم ان هناك تقريبا سبعه عشر شاحنه الان
متوقفه على الطرف التركي البوابه التركيه
بانتظار العبور ربما مع بدء اعمال يوم غد
وبالتالي هذه
تدخل فقط خلال ايام العمل وساعات العمل
الرسميه اشكرك على كل هذه المعلومات مسلم
يعني اعطيتنا صوره لحد ما عن المناطق
وخاصه جنديرس وحارم كيف هو الوضع فيها
الان ايضا قلت بانه انتشلوا تقريبا اليوم
او خلال 24 ساعه الماضيه 55 جثه اضيفت الى
الالاف التي احصيت بالسابق وطبعا اعطيتنا
صوره عن المساعدات التي تدخل عبر معبر باب
الهوى اشكرك من معبر باب الهوى الصحفي
مسلم السيد عيسى
مخيمات فجرتهم الارض مره اخرى
هنا ريف ادلب هي ذاتها الارض التي اهتزت
قبل اكثر من اسبوع تحت قاطينها لتدمر ما
بقي من منازل بكل قسوتها تستقبل الذين
نزحوا مرتين او ربما اكثر
بعضهم وصفوا الكارثه التي ضربتهم بالرعب
الذي يفوق رعب الحرب
صار عمري 36 سنه اكلنا طيران وغزايف
وبرابيل وما خفنا مثل هالخوف هاي الرابعه
بتاريخ حياتي صار ما ما شفت من اكبر من
هالرعبه هاي
حسينا ولا هذه ارضيه قويه والله
وما حسيت غير تحت الدردين
الحمد لله
ما زادت معاناه نازحي الزلزال
ليكونوا هم الضحيه وهم فرق واغاثه النفس
في الوقت ذاته انا احد المتطوعين في بلده
كله سمعنا في نداء استغاثه لاخواتنا هون
عم يعملوا لهم
عشره ايام الجراء الزلزالي لحدث والدمار
اللي ساوى بها البيوت
[موسيقى]
بعض من المنظمات المحليه تحاول بما تملك
من امكانيات بسيطه ان تمد يد العون سواء
بتامين الخيام والقليل من القوه البشريه
العامله او بمعونه بسيطه قامت منظمه
بانشاء واستجابه
المراكز الهواء في مناطق ارمناز ومعرض
مصرين وجنديرس بالاضافه الى الاتارب
والتوامه وحارم
اخر عقد في التنقل واللجوء الى اي مامن او
ما ظنوا انه المامن الا ان الارض نفسها لم
تعد تحتمل معاناتهم
وعمر العربيه
[تصفيق]
الجدار الحدودي بين تركيا وسوريا لم يمنع
سكان الاخيره من رؤيه اختلاف التعامل مع
الكارثه في البلدين ففي جهتهم سوريون
يشعرون بالخذلان منسيون من الانقاذ
والمساعدات العاجله
وغضب مشاعر تختلط بالبرد والفقد والدموع
السوريون حملوا مجددا اكياس الجثث التي
اعتادوا حملها لسنوات بعضهم حظي باقامه
طقوس وداعا وان كانت مختصره والبعض الاخر
لا يزال بمرحله انتظار خروجهم من تحت
الانقاض
الحرقه لم تزل ببدايتها لكن الغضب عارم لم
يعتادوا البقاء في الصف الخلفي رغم اهمال
اوضاعهم لسنوات فصرخاتهم ليست لغطاء او
طعام رغم ضاله المساعدات التي وصلت الى
الشمال غرب سوريا وانعدامها ببعض المناطق
ما اريد اكل نريد ناكل التراب بس انحفظ
كرامتنا السوريون يصفونه بالتخلي
والنسيانه مع التماسهم لفروق كثيره في
التعامل المحلي والدولي مع جيرانهم
الاتراك شركائهم بالكارثه والدمار الكارثه
لم تقدر حدودا لكن الجدار بينهما حدد وحدد
خدمات كثيره من الانقاذ للاسعاف للماوى
فعلى الجهه الاخرى من الجدار الاف عمال
الانقاذ والالاف من المسعفين اضافه الى
معدات رفع ثقيله وجرافات وكلاب بوليسيه
تجب الشوارع صخب محركات ضغط عليه احيانا
صافره سيارات الاسعاف وزحام المساعدات لكن
في الجهه السوريه وقفت عمليات الانقاذ منذ
يومين صمت مستغرب تحتمه امكانات محدوده مع
تفوق الكارثه على قدرات الخوض البيضاء
نقاط التفتيش احبطت جهود الاغاثه الدوليه
والمساعده العاجله في الجزء الذي تسيطر
عليه الفصائل المدعومه من تركيا
والمساعدات المنتظره تعرقل دخولها لاكثر
من منطقه بسبب تقسيمات جغرافيه وانقسامات
سياسيه وولائيه
والان ينضم الي مراسل العربيه جمعه عكاش
جمعه اهلا بك معنا اين تتواجد الان
وماذا لدينا من تفاصيل حول هذه المساعدات
وفتح بعض المعابر اليوم
مساء الخير ميسون لك والانساده المشاهدين
ان نتواجد في مدينه منبج في الصباح وظهيره
وقبل حلول الليل كنت في معبرين الاول ام
يربط مناطق الاداره مع مناطق المعارضه في
هذا المعبر تم فتحه للمره الاولى امام
قوافل المساعدات دخل من المعبر في البدايه
شاحنه لاطباء بلا حدود تكون اول شاحنات
تدخل من مناطق الاداره الذاتيه الى مناطق
المعادله اما المعارضه 32 شاحنه مقدمه من
سكان مدينه منبج واريافها اضافه الى عشرين
شاحنه اخرى من مناطق اخرى في سوريا يعني
53 شاحنه دخلت من معبر ام جلود الذي بقي
مغلقا في اسبوع كامل امام هذه المساعدات
في المعبر نفسه لا تزال 30 شاحنه من
الوقود مقدمه من الاداره الذاتيه عالقه
ولم تدخل باتجاه الشمال الغد تابع لماذا
لماذا ادخلت هذه الشاحنات اليوم انما
شاحنات الوقود لم تدخل بعد
ما الذي يحول دون ذلك يعني بقرار من بقرار
من المعارضه وحكومتها يمكن للاهالي
والمنظمات ادخال المساعدات لكن يمنع في
وجه المساعدات الرسميه المقدمه من الاداره
في دخول المعابر نفس الموضوع ايضا في معبر
عن الدادات ميسون دخلت 66 شاحنه محلى
المساعدات الانسانيه والاغاثيه مع بعض
المعبر المساء او بعد فتره ظهيره باتجاه
ايضا المناطق المعارضه من الواضح ان
المعارضه لا تريد التعامل مع الاداره
الذاتيه لذلك تقفل هذه المعابر في وجه
المساعدات المقدمه من طرفها المسؤولون
الاكراد يعيدون ذلك الى رفض ادخال اي نوع
من انواع المساعدات كلا يحدث اي تقارب بين
الفصائل العسكريه المواليه لها وبين خصمها
اللدود في الشمال الشرقي ويقصدون بها قسم
طيب بالنسبه للمعابر الاخرى ايضا الجمعه
ماذا لدينا من تفاصيل حولها ما هي طبيعه
المساعدات التي تدخل هل هذه المعابر
مفتوحه كل الاوقات
الميسون هناك معبر ايضا في المناطق التي
اقف فيها يسمى بالتائهه يربط مناطق
الاداره مع مناطق النظام هناك 100 شاحنه
من الوقود لا تزال عالقه اضافه الى
الشاحنات اخرى من مقدمه من الهلال الاحمر
الكردي النظام يفاوض على استحواذ على حصه
الاسد من هذه
المساعدات والاكراد يرفضون اليوم صباحا
كان هناك شكل اخر من اشكال التفاوض لتسهيل
ادخال هذه المساعدات نظام قال بانه يجب ان
يستلم هذه المساعدات عبر الهلال الاحمر
لكن يعني طرف الكردي كان يصير ان يقوم
بادخالها الى مخيم مخيمات الشهداء حيث
العشرات من الالاف من النازحيه عفرين
وايضا الى ايصالها الى
حيي الاشرفيه والشيخ مقصود في وسط مدينه
حلب لا يزال المعبر مغلق ايضا ميسون في
المناطق الاخرى في المناطق
يعني المناطق الحدا المعابر الحدوديه بين
النظام
والمعارضه لا يزال معبر سراقب مغلق لان هي
تحرير الشام ترفض استقبال اي مساعدات سوى
في حل لو اراد النظامي صالح الى المناطق
الشماليه الغربيه او المنظمات الانسانيه
العامله في مناطق النظام ميسون في مطارات
دمشق وحلب واللاذقيه تم استقبال اكثر من
50 طائره حتى الان من عدد كبير من الدول
العربيه الامارات مصر سلطنه عمان الجزائر
ليبيا والاردن هذه المساعدات تدخل عن طريق
هيئه الاغاثه السوريه والهلال الاحمر
السوري وتوزع على المنكوبين في مدن
اللاذقيه وجبله وطرطوس حماه ومركز مدينه
حلب ولا يصل اي شيء منها الى المناطق
الشماليه الغربيه المنكوبه واقسط تلك
الواقعه تحت السيطره المعارضه طيب بالنسبه
لهذه المناطق الخاضعه الى سيطره النظام
كجبله وغيرها من المناطق ماذا لدينا من
تفاصيل حول اوضاعها هل ما زالت عمليات رفع
الانقاذ ما زالت مستمره هل هناك مثلا
اليات ورافعات تكفي
لعمليات انتشال الجثث ورفع الانقاض بما
انه طبعا اصبحت الامل يعني تتضاءل بايجاد
ايناجين في اليوم الثامن
ميسون يعني فرق البحث والانقاذ كثافه
جهودها بمشاركه فريق الجزائري واخر مينا
الصين واخر من الجزائر
ووحدات من الجيش الروسي ساعدوا يعني
الجهات المعنيه والمسؤوله في مناطق
المنكوبه خاصه في اللاذقيه وحلب وجبله
توقفت اعمال البحث والانقاذ في يعني كاول
مدينه في مدينه حماه تم انتشار 43 جلسه من
هذه المدينه ثم توقفت في مركز مدينه حلب
التي شهدت دمار 54 مبنى وشادد اكثر من 500
قتيل الان الاعمال تتركز في بعض المباني
في جبله وايضا في مركز مدينه اللاذقيه
ويتم انتشال جثه من حوالي ثلاثه ايام يعني
انقاذ شخصين وبعدها توقفت الاخبار عن
الوصول الى اي ناجين ايضا يعني في مناطق
المعارضه سراقب الاتارب حارم توقفت تقريبا
الاعمال من مرحله الانقاذ الى مرحله انت
يعني التركيز كله الان على بلده هناك حتى
الان 20 مبنى لم يتم الوصول اليها من قبل
الفرق البحث والانقاذ التي لا تزال تعاني
من غياب الاليات الثقيله او الجرافات وحتى
نقاءات والمعدات المتوسطه والصغيره التي
تساعد في الوصول الى الجثث او الاحياء مثل
المجلسات او الكاميرات الحراريه لم تدخل
هذه المساعدات حتى هذه اللحظات الى مناطق
شمال غرب البلاد يا جماعه كاش مراسل
العربيه كنت معي من منبج اشكرك على كل هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل
في سوريا يصعب تحديد حجم الاضرار
الاقتصاديه التي اصابت البلاد مقارنه
بالجانب التركي وذلك بسبب الاوضاع
السياسيه المنقسمه ومعاناه البلاد من حرب
مستمره منذ اكثر من 12 عاما المزيد في
التقرير التالي
خسائر متزايده في الارواح والاملاك
والاقتصاد سببه الزلزال المدمر الذي اصاب
سوريا الاسبوع الماضي ليضيف معاناه اضافيه
لاقتصاد انهكته صراعات سياسيه لاكثر من 12
عاما وما زالت مستمره غياب البيانات
الرسميه والشفافيه واتساع رقعات تاثير
الزلزال بين مناطق خاضعه للنظام واخرى
للمعارضه يزيدان من صعوبه تقدير حجم
الاضرار والتي تجاوزت بالمجمل عشرات
المليارات من الدولارات
وحول الخسائر الماديه افادت منظمه الخوه
البيضاء بان اكثر من 300 وخمسه وسبعين
مبنى انهار كليا واكثر من 1200 مبنى انهار
جزئيا كما تصدعت الاف المباني الاخرى
كما اصاب زلزال اقتصاد سوريا في مقتل خاصه
انه ضرب اربعه محافظات مسؤوله عن اكثر من
ثلث اقتصاد البلاد
فمحافظه حلب المتاثره الاكبر من الزلزال
مسؤوله عن اكثر من 16% من اقتصاد سوريا
فيما تمثل محافظه حماه المرتبه الخامسه
بنسبه مساهمه في الاقتصاد السوري بما يصل
الى تسعه في المئه ثم اللاذقيه في المرتبه
السادسه بسبعه فاصل ثمانيه في المئه
مساهمه بالاقتصاد اما محافظه ادلب التي
تنقسم السيطره فيها بين النظام والمعارضه
والمتاثره بالزلزال تصل مساهمتها في
الاقتصاد الى 2.7
انقسام الوضع السياسي في سوريا يزيد من
معاناه المتاثرين بالزلزال المدمر اعاده
الاعمار على الجانب السوري خاصه في
المناطق التي تخضع للمعارضه والتي في
الاصل تضم مئات الالاف من المهجرين ستكون
الاصعب في غياب رقابه حكوميه وهرب من
المسؤوليه من المنظمات الانسانيه الدوليه
شادي الزعيم العربيه
من اسطنبول لا ينضم الي المهندس الاستشاري
مظهر شربجي استاذ مظهر اهلا بكم معنا مع
ارتفاع عدد ضحايا
الزلزال في تركيا الى اكثر من 31 الفا
التساؤلات الان لدى من فقدوا احبائهم لدى
من شردوا من منازلهم حول معايير البناء في
تركيا وسبب هذا الدمار الهائل اذا اردنا
نتحدث عن معايير بناء مضاده للزلازل ماذا
يمكن ان تعطينا من معلومات وتفاصيل حولها
مساء الخير لك وللمشاهدين الكرام والرحمه
للشهداء والشفاء للجرحى والسلامه للمباني
السالمه الباقيه ان شاء الله
عزيزتي بعد زلزال 1999 لضرب تركيا وبعد
تسونامي في اليابان تم اعتماد معايير
دوليه لدراسه الابنيه على الزلازل وتسمى
بالكودات منها الكود السوري ومنها الكود
التركيه وكلها معتمده على معايير دوليه
وهذه المعايير تم اتفاق على دوليا
واتفقت بعض الدول على تطبيقها منا تركيا
وتشيلي والصين وايطاليا ولكن بالتنفيذ
للاسف هذه المعايير غير مطبقه على الارض
ولا يوجد رقابه يعني نقول دقيقه وهذا
المظهر اريد ان استوضح هذه الكودات التي
تتحدث عنها والتي تلتزم بها كل الدول
المعرضه الى الزلازل هل هي كافيه يعني اذا
تم
العمل بهذه المعايير هل نحمي البناء من
السقوط كليا ام تكون الاضرار اقل يعني هذا
ما يريد الناس ان تفهموا
نعم
تم تقسيم الابنيه الى نوعين ابنيه تحت سبع
الطوابق وابنيه فوق لحد العشرين طابق
والابنيه اللي فوق العشرين لكل منها
معايير الميه السكنيه او ابنيه اللي تحت
السبع طوابق تم اعتماد معايير اسمها
اشتراطات
لحمايه الزلازل او مقاومته اما ما بين
السبعه والعشرين طابق وتسمى الابنيه
العاليه بما فيهم اسطنبول او اي مدينه
اخرى يجب ان يكون المبنى مدروسا على
الزلازل لمقاومه تصل الى السبعه رختر اما
بعد ذلك سيتم وضع معايير مثل اليابان كما
حدث في اليابان بتطبيق نظريات مختلفه
باي زلزال تحميها حقيقه من السقوط اذا تم
العمل بهذه المعايير
تقلل من ضرر يعني لا يقع البناء بشكل كامل
ممكن ان ينكسر وينحما هناك جدران كامله من
المسلحه تكون مدروسه بطريقه مختلفه بحيث
يتم البناء يتهزهز ولا ينكسر كما تفتت
ونشاهده في بعض الابنيه الموجوده انهيار
كامل الامن التي سقطت بشكل كامل في صراحه
هناك في شيء غريب نتفاجئ فيه انه بنائين
بجانب بعضهم بنفس الارتفاع احدهم سقط
واحدهم وقف واقف حتى الان مثلا هناك يعني
اعطي مثل عن دار المهندسين او بنايه
المهندسين هي بقيت يعني لم تسقط بينما
مختلف البيوت الاخرى او البنايات الاخرى
سقطت ما الذي ميز هذا البناء حتى استطاع
الصمود
هو اتوقع انه نموذج للدراسه الهندسيه
نفذوه بطريقه وطبقوا المعايير على بنائهم
ولم يراقبوا تطبيق المعايير على الاغنياء
الاخرى الموجوده في الابنيه السكنيه وهذا
يحتاج الى رقابه رقابه من جهه اخرى من طرف
اخر
مهندسين
بلديات الى اخره في جهات مسؤوله يجب ان
تراقب تنفيذ المباني ومن المسؤول من
المسؤول عن هذا الاهمال اذا اردنا ان
نتحدث بانه يبدو بان الكل يجمع بانه هناك
اهمال من المسؤول عن هذا الاهمال من يجب
ان يحاسب يعني تم توقيف 150 شخصا وبالسابق
ايضا تم توقيف العديد من المقاولين ولكن
ايضا في النهايه لم تتم محاكمتهم او كان
هناك من بعض الاعفاءات فالسؤال من المسؤول
من يجب ان يحاسب
انا ساتحدث عن سوريا سوريا هناك نقابه
المهندسين هي الجهه الجهه التي مسؤوله عن
الدراسه وعن مهندسين المشرفين اما
البلديات او الوحدات الاداريه يجب ان تذهب
مع كل صبه اي جمله انشائيه اعمد او سقف او
اساس لا يتم بناؤه الا موافقه اذن صب وهذا
الاذن هو مطابقه للمعايير المخططات وكل
عمليه تنفيذ باي جزء هيكل ضمن هيكل البناء
يجب ان يكون موافقه مع الموافقه على صب
الاعمده مع موافقه صب الاساسات مع
الموافقه على السقف هذه الموافقات كلها
تحمل المسؤوليه للطرفين انا اتوقع هذا
الشيء غير موجود في بعض الدوائر لكن في
بعض المؤسسات نعم وهذا خلل كبير يجب ان
يعاد النظر في حاليا اما في في تركيا
تم اعطاء المهندس صلاحيات كامله المهندس
لتحمل مسؤوليته كونه اخذها ترخيصا على
اسمه ان يقوم بالاعمال والبلديه مهمتها
مراقبه فهون يجب ان نبحث هل هذا البناء
فيه موافقات على اذون الصب الرسميه وفق
المخططات المدروسه من النقابه ولتحملها
اذا كان هناك نقول ان هذه من عند الله هزه
ارضيه وقد اما اذا كان في خلل في التنفيذ
تتحمل هذه الجهات المسؤوليه كامله شكرا لك
من اسطنبول المهندسه الاستشاري بمظهر
شربجي على المشاركه معنا
بخوف وحذر تهافت رجال الانقاذ الانتشاله
ليستقبلهم هو بضحكاته البريئه انه رضيع
الانقاض الضاحك ابن الستين يوما صمد امام
الزلزال المدمر وبقي تحت الركام لخمسه
ايام في انطاكيا التركيه وحين خرج للنور
تغلبت براءته على معاناته وضحك
الرضيع الضاحك شغل الجميع منذ لحظه نقله
الى المستشفى في مدينه اضنه التركيه
بقي الصغير تحت الانقاض لمده خمسه ايام ثم
نقل الى المستشفى بواسطه الاسعاف الجويه
لكن حالته العامه جيده فهو بخير الطفل
الضاحك مجهول الهويه لا يعرف اسمه ولم يتم
التوصل الى والديه حتى الان لكن الطاقم
المستشفى الذين يعملون جاهدين لرعايته
اكدوا انه سيبقى معهم بعد ان اسر قلوبهم
بضحكاته البريئه
ملوك الشيخ العربيه
خارجون من ركام الزلزال
انقاذ طفله من حضن اختها التي فارقت
الحياه
اخراج طفله من انقاذ منزلها بعد 24 ساعه
من الزلزال
رضيع ينجو من انهيار منزله
صبي يخرج حيا بعد ثلاثه ايام من الزلزال
ما شاء الله
انقاذ طفله ووالدها بعد 100 ساعه من
الزلزال
العثور على ناجيه قضت خمسه ايام تحت
الانقاض
انقاذ طفله بعد 150 ساعه من الزلزال
في ناحيه جنديرس السوريه لم يتوقع طفل
محمد ان يجد نفسه بين ليله وضحاها من دون
ماوى ويتيم الاهل بعد كارثه زلزال المدمر
الذي راح بين ركامه والداه وشقيقاته او
اتبقت له من اسرته زوجه عمي والدته اسبين
مرجان من قرخان التركيه
ما لامح الحزن والالم وخيبه الامل تبدو
واضحه على ملامح الطفل محمد عقيد الذي فقد
كل عائلته في جنديرس السوريه محمد لم يكن
يتوقع ان تنقلب حياته بين ليله وضحاها
ليصبح يتيما بعد ان كانت الطفل المدلل في
وسط عائلته ليجد نفسه اليوم بدون ماوى بعد
الزلزال الذي حول منزله الى حطام راح بين
ركامه والداه وشقيقاته وتبقى له من اسرته
زوجه عمي والدته ياسمين مرجان من قرخانه
التركيه
انا تركيا انا واطفالي هدم بنا المنزل في
جنديرس وليس لدينا اي مكان للبقاء فيه ليس
لدينا منزل اريد الخروج من المستشفى لكن
للاسف ليس لدينا مكان ياوينا اريد ان تتم
مساعدتها هذا الطفل
محمد بعد ان كان وحيدا لاهله اصبح وحيدا
لزوجه عمي والدته التركيه الاصل وهما
الناجيان الوحيدان من كل الاسره جراء
الزلزال المدمر في ناحيه جنديرس السوريه
[موسيقى]
اريد الخروج من المستشفى حتى تتحسن صحه
ابني انا تركيا وبسوريا ليس لدينا اشخاص
نذهب عندهم اريد ان يتم تقديم المساعدات
لي
هول الصدمه لا يزال باديا عجز عن الكلام
والتعبير فالموقف لا تقوى تلك الملامح على
تحمله او حتى على الاقل تقبله
من جنديرساي ينضم اليها الصحفي محمد
الاشقر محمد اهلا بك معنا الوضع اليوم في
جنديرس اين وصلت عمليه رفع الانقاذ كم هو
عدد الجثث التي تم انتشالها اليوم
نعم في الحقيقه يعني انتهت عمليات مسح
جميع المباني التي تدمرت بشكل كامل هنا في
مدينه
جنديرس يعني ولكن لا زالت فرق الدفاع
المدني تنتشر في جميع الاحياء يعني
انتظارا لاحتماليه ورود انباء او اخباريه
عن عن وجود ضحايا تحت الانقاض الى حد هذه
اللحظه خصوصا ان عدد المفقودين الى حد هذه
اللحظه يعني لا هو عدد لا باس فيه اغلب
الناس يبحثون عن اقاربهم اما في
المستشفيات او المشافي الميدان الميدانيه
او المراكز الطبيه او حتى في يعني مراكز
الايواء المؤقته المنتشره في
العموم المنطقه في شمال غرب سوريا يعني
بالنسبه لاعداد الضحايا هنا في في مدينه
جنديرس يعني هناك احصائيه قريبه قد
الى 600 قتيل منذ بدايه هذه الكارثه حتى
هذا اليوم وهي احصائيه غير رسميه الى حد
هذه اللحظه غياب الاحصائيات الرسميه كان
بسبب يعني عدد المباني الكبير المدمر في
داخل هذه المدينه وغيرها من المباني
واعداد الضحايا المرتفعه بشكل كبير مما
ادى الى الى يعني يعني تعداد الفرق
الميدانيه وفرق الانقاذ فرق انتشال
الضحايا يصعب في الوقت الحالي الحديث عن
احصائيه رسميه ولكن هناك ناشطون بداوا
بالعمل على جمع احصائيه بالارقام لاعداد
الضحايا سواء كان المتوفين او المصابين
نجوم هل هناك من السكان مازالوا متواجدين
في جنديرس هل هناك من بيوت ما زالت صالحه
للعيش فيها هل يمكن ان تصف لنا هذه
المدينه الان
نعم يعني في الحقيقه مدينه جنديرس تصدرت
المشهد الاعلامي بسبب ما نالته من الدمار
واعداد الضحايا اكثر من 80% من منازل
المدينه هي غير صالحه للسكن فجزء كبير
منها قد تدمر بشكل كامل هناك احياء كامله
تدمرت مثل حيي الصناعه وسوق الهال الذين
تدمر بشكل كامل وهناك العديد من المنازل
التي
تصدعت وهي غير صالحه للسكن وتسبب في الوقت
الحالي خطرا على المدنيين طبعا هناك حركه
في المدينه هناك العديد من الاهالي الذين
عادوا الى منازلهم المتصدعه الغير صالحه
للسكن بغيه اخذ بعض احتياجاتهم التي
تعينهم نوعا ما على العيش في المراكز التي
لجاوا اليها سواء كان في المخيمات او
مراكز الايواء او عند اقربائهم في القرى
والبلدات الاكثر امنا التي لم يطالها
هذا الزلزال طبعا يعني حتى البيوت الصالحه
للسكن نسبه قليله جدا من الاهالي يعني
عادوا الى منازلهم هناك حاله خوف شديده
خصوصا لدى الاطفال نتيجه ما نتيجه اللحظات
التي عاشوها لحظه وقوع الكارثه العديد من
الاهالي لا يدخل منزله ولكن يفترش
الساحه الاماميه لمنزله خوفا من هبوط
المنزل خصوصا ان المنطقه لا تزال تتعرض
لهزات ارتداديه وهذا الشيء هو الذي يمثل
حاله الخوف لدى الاهالي هنا يعني
مستمره حتى اليوم محمد هل شعرتم باي هزه
ارتداديه مثلا اليوم
نعم نعم يعني بحسب يعني ما شعرنا به فقد
حدثت هزه عصر هذا اليوم ضرب يعني شعر فيها
فيها سكان المدينه هذه الهزات هي التي
تسبب حاله الخوف والهلع هنا في شوارع
المدينه السؤال هنا دائما هل هذه هل هذه
الهزات قد تدمر بمنازل هل سيعود الزلزال
ويضرب من جديد المنطقه يعني في الحقيقه
لحظه في
اشكرك محمد اعذرني انتهى وقت هذا المقابله
نشكرك على هذه المعلومات من جنديرس
الصحفيه محمد الاشقر
كل شيء هنا بات حطاما وكل شيء يذكر بهول
ما حدث وبحجم الماساه ليس الركام فقط بل
وجوه من بقوا وغارت في انفسهم هزات زلزال
وارتداداته في جنديرس المتاخمه للحدود
التركيه شماليه حلب ما تزال عشرات العوائل
تحت ركام بيوتها بانتظار من يكرمهم بدفن
كمن سبقوهم هنا في جنديرس تكشف الصوره هول
الكارثه التي حلت بالسكان
فاحدى اكثر المدن السوريه المتضرره
بالزلزال دفعت قرابه الف من ارواح ابنائها
بينما ماتزال عوائل باكملها حبيسه هذا
الحطام تقول الفرق المدنيه والميدانيه ان
اكتضاض المدينه بالمهجرين من المدن الاخرى
جراء الحرب احد ابرز الاسباب في هذا العدد
الكبير للضحايا
عدا عن تعداد سكانها وقربها نسبيا من مركز
الزلزال اسبوع مر على الكارثه ومحاولات
الانقاذ توقفت لتتركز العمليات على اغاثه
من حالفهم الحظ وبقوا على قيد الحياه
لتبقى الحصيله النهائيه للارواح حبيسه
الركام حتى اشعار اخر
قال ياسر طرافه منسق لاستجابه الطارئه في
الجمعيات الدوليه لرعايه الكوارث والذي
يعمل في مخيم الاغاثه السعودي في جنديرس
بشمال غرب سوريا قال ان عمليه توزيع
المساعدات السعوديه التي وصلت من مركز
الملك سلمان للاغاثه في جنديرس بدات
طبعا بدايه بحب اذكر انه اول شيء الطائره
دخلت من خلال معبر جوي اغاثه بين المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وبين تركيا طبعا هذه
الطائرات دخل منها الى سوريا قافيه واحده
اللي هي عباره عن 11 شحنه بقيه الحملات
حيث يتم توزيعها بين سوريا وبتركيا
بالنسبه للجانب السوري فاللي دخل هو عباره
عن 11 شاحنه من خلال معبر الحمام الحروري
مع تركيا هاي الشواحين تتضمن عده مواد
اللي هي مواد غذائيه خلال غذائيه ومواد
غير غذائيه اللي هي طبعا كانت عباره عن
خيم وسلال واغطيه
للناس اللي ضررت يؤثر الزلزال اللي صار
جنوب تركيا وشمال سوريا طبعا هاي
الموادعها بمناطق ادلب ومناطق عفرين احنا
حاليا متواجدين بوسط من ناحيه جنديرس عم
نقوم ببناء واحد المخيمات طبعا هذا المخيم
رقم ثلاثه اللي احنا عم نباشر فيه ان شاء
الله وغدا الفرق راح تكون متواجده بمناطق
ادلب لا ان شاء الله رب العالمين حنحاول
نوصل لاكبر عدد ممكن من خلال الفتره
القادمه
المصور ان ان يعني ان يدخل قليلا الى الى
الخيام ولكن التجهيزات هنا تخوننا دائما
التجهيزات الانترنت صعوبه التواصل تخوننا
دائما في الدخول بين الاهالي ولكن في
النشرات القادمه سندخل بين الاهالي
سنستضيفهم طبعا كما تلاحظون على شاشه
الكاميرا هناك العديد من العوائل التي اتت
الى هنا تنتظر الانتهاء من بناء هذه
الخيام لكي يستلموها لكي يؤمنوا انفسهم
بعد ايام عصيبه مرت عليهم في ظل موجات
البرد الشديده التي تضرب المنطقه ليل
الامس يعني صراحه كانت درجه الحراره هنا
ناقص درجتان اغلب هؤلاء الاهالي كانوا
يبيتون في مراكز الايواء المؤقته منهم من
كان يبيت امام منزله المدمر بشكل جزئي
يخاف دخوله نتيجه يعني وجود هزات ارتداديه
تحدث بين الحين والاخر
من نتائج جنوب تركيا ينضم اليه مفرد
العربيه عمار الهندي عمار اهلا بك معنا
تجولت اليوم في الكثير من مراكز وكان هناك
الكثير من القصص المؤثره
والماساويه تحدثت الى تجارب بعض الناس
خلال هذا الزلزال هل يمكن ان توجز لنا
مشاهداتك هذا اليوم
ميسون بالفعل نحن لا نزلنا امام مركز
للايواء الذي يعني تتوافد اليه السيارات
التي تنقل السوريين الذين تقطعت بهم السبل
بعد ان انهدمت منازلهم ولكن الان للتو
يعني التقيت صدفه بهذا الشاب وبيني وبينه
حكايه قبل ايام كنت التقيت وسط
انطاكيا الى جانب بنايه وكان يجلس وفي
جانبه جثث مجهوله الهويه وكانت ساعات
متاخره من الليل توقفت وتحدثت اليه
واخبرني بانها جثث خرجت من مبنى ولا
يعرفون لمن تعود وكان موقف يعني
مؤثر جدا لانه كان وبصحبته
ناشطين يبحثون عن اي شخص يتعرف على هذه
الجثث الان شاهدت للصدفه وذكرني بنفسي
وانا اشكر ولذلك موضوع الجثث مجهوله
الهويه وما الذي يحدث معها امر هام جدا
لذلك اسمحي لي ان يعني اتجه قليلا في
الحوار الى هذا الشاب عن هذا الامر اولا
بدي اذكرك بالقصه انت تذكرتها جيدا في
حينه لمن عادت تلك الجثث الاربعه التي
رايتها انا لمين طلعت اجا اخوها
اخوه للشاب وهو
بيكون اخوه وزوجته واثنين اطفال اجا اخونا
الشاب يتعرف عليهم وكيف عرفوا الاسره
بوجودهم كيف اندلوا انه انتو عندكم الجثث
هون اجوا على الموقع البناء مع العنوان
عارف يعني وين اخوه ساكن اتطلع على
البنايه بيعرفوا انه هاي البنايه ساكن
فيها ناس
اخوه ومرت اخوه وكلهم طبعا طلعوا
تعرف عليهم وعرف انهم كانت عباره عن اغلب
سكانها من السوريين كل الضحايا لقيناهم
ببيت الدرج الا الاخت اللي كانت تعادل عنا
لقيناها لسه طبعا مطبقه على اخر البنايه
هيك الحال عم يصير كل الناس اللي واقف له
قرايبين عم يجوا يوقفوا عند بنايتهم
ويجيبوا فرق الانقاذ والاليات انا كنت شفت
الجثه تبقى 24 ساعه جنب البنايه اذا اجت
حدا تعرف عليها بياخدها ما اجابته لمقبره
الارقام للمقبره الجديد تدفن بعد تصويرها
مع رقم صحيح وهذول الناس هذا اللي حدث
معهم انت بتقولي لثاني يوم في جثث ظلت
لثاني يوم قال لسه باقي العيله ما طلعت من
تحت الانقاذ بالسنه مشان ياخذوهم عائله
كامله او انه ما تعرف عليها تستنى لتاني
يوم الصبح وبعدين بكملوا بكون انت الان
عدت من هناك لسه في جثث بتطلع كم
اعداد كبيره نحن شلون طريقه البحث راح
تكون بعطونا مثلا بخابرونا بيقولوا لنا
انه بالمجموعات انه فيها هذا العنوان في
عيله سبع اشخاص مثلا او شخصين مفقودين وما
عملاقيهم بالمشاكل بنروح بدنا ناخذ منه
عنوان صحيح
نعيط الاليات نعرض نعيط فرق الانقاذ لانه
بخلونا نقرب
تامن على حالي عبر واتساب او حدا نداء
تروحوا للموقع بتبحثوا وبتطلعوا الجثث
وبتخرجوها وبتيجي الناس تتعرف عليها واذا
في حال ما تعرفوا عليها شو بتعملوا نوديها
عند المقابر والمقابر الجديده ايوه
النائب العام يصورها وبعطيها رقم
اذا ما في ما حدا متعرف عليه ما بيعملوا
شهاده
لحتى يمكن تخلصوا الازمه او يتجاوزوها
اشكرك جدا ميسون انا اسمحي لي كمان سريعا
انا اتحدث الى هذا الفريق من الشبان
السوريين جاؤوا للتو من وسط الركام هم
يعملون منذ بدايه الازمه قاموا باخراج
اشخاص على قيد الحياه لهم تجارب سريعه
واسمحي لي ان استفسر منهم عن بعض الامور
تحياتي انت الاختيار ان نتحدث اليك اولا
يعطيكم الف عافيه على جهودكم
كم جثه على قيد كم شخص على قيد الحياه
اخرجتوه وكم جثه لمتوفي تقريبا الله
يعافيك على قناه الحدث العربيه العربيه
القناه الحدث العربيه نشكره على وصول
المناطق نحن شبان من قريه اسمها شحروره من
باير بوجاك وبعد هذه الزلزال سبحان الله
هذا طوعتم للمساعده المساعده هذه الاشخاص
تحت الركام الحمد لله تم بعون الله سبحانه
وتعالى اخراج ما بين عشره او 15 شخص قيد
الحياه وما يقارب شي 20 شخص متوفين متى
اخر حاله اخرجتوها كانت على قيد الحياه
قبل يومين يعني في خمس ايام بعد زلزال
اخرجنا طفلين الحمد لله
الحدث معنا موقفين هم استغربت منهم مواقف
غريبه بدي اسالك عن المواقف الغريبه اول
منهم عائله تركيه اخرجهم طبعا نحن
كما سمعنا الصوت نخرج بعون الله نخرج
السمعنا الصوت ان كان تركي او
مافي تمييز افهمك افهم سبحان الله عائله
تركيه اخرجناهم الله تمينا شي ثلاث ساعات
حتى نقدر نوصل لعندهم بعد ما وصلنا الاخت
طلعت سليم ما فيها شيء
والرجل علق اجره تحت الاركان بين الباطون
تمينا اربعه او ثلاث ساعات كمان بس
التحرير رجله سبحان الله اخر شيء فقد
الامل وقال اقطع اجري
يا الله اي والله قال اقطع اجري واخرجني
قلت له لا يا اخي ان شاء الله انا بدي
احاول لحتى احرر سبحان الله الحمد لله
الله عز وجل فتحته وتخلى عن رجله حتى
يلحظه اي والله عن رجله حتى يخرج من بدنه
الحمد لله الله عز وجل وحررنا الموقف
الاخر لانه ما عندناش وقت كثير اسف بس
يعني موقف الاخر سبحان الله اخرجنا الطفل
في عمر 11 سنه
قبل ما نوصل لعنده سالناه مين معك قال
خالتي وابن خالتي قلنا له مين متوفي قال
بس لاخرج ان شاء الله انا استغربت من زكاه
الطفل قال بس ان شاء الله اخرج نتكلم بعد
ما خرج قال خالتي عايشه وابنها متوفي
سبحان الله جوا ما قال هذا الحكي مشان ما
يسمع خالتو خالتو ما بتعرف انه انه ابن
متوفي عشان ما يجرحها يعني عشان عشان ما
يجرحها تحت الركام طيب انا بدي اسالك عشان
الضيق الوقت واسف انتم جئتم من هناك للتو
وغدا صباحا راح تتوجهوا للعمل مره اخرى
سؤال مهم من خبرتكم واللي بتشتغلوه هل
يتزال هنالك اعداد كبيره من الجثث تحت
الركام برايك والله اداه كثيره اعداد
قليله للخروج من تعطيكم اعداد كثيره جدا
جدا لا تزال لا تزال اعداد كثيره تحت
الركام يعني اعداد قليله اللي خرجوا قياسا
باللي بقوا طب السؤال كمان اخيرا باعتقادك
هذا الدمار
الموجود في انطاكيا وفي هاتاي من خبرتكم
وانتم بتشوفوا المواقع كم يحتاج من الوقت
برايك حتى يزال كل الركام وتخرج كل الجثث
من تحته يعني تقريبا هلا كل جزء اساسي
يخرج من تحت هذا صعب لانه في مناطق ما
يخرج منه قصدي كم يحتاج اسبوع شهر كم عده
اشهر شهرين او
شهرين او شهر وما فوق يعني عدد اشهر ميسون
انا اعتذر عن الايطالي ولكن وددت ان اسال
هذا السؤال لانه اود ان يهمنا يعني كمان
ان نسمع هذه التجارب اشكرك دائما نعود
اليك عمار ساذهب الان الى غازي عنتاب مع
مفرد العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي ايضا
منطلع منه على الاوضاع في غازي عنتابه عبد
المحسن اهلا بك معنا وضع غازي عنتاب اليوم
وعمليه الانقاذ اين وصلت
نعم ميسون بالفعل لا تزال عمليات رفع
الانقاذ من المناطق المختلفه التي يضربها
الزلزال في غازي عنتابه ونتحدث عن ابراهيم
لي والمنطقه الاكثر تضررا في غازي عنتاب
وهي اصلاحيه التي لا تزال فيها عمليات رفع
الانقاض مستمره حتى هذه اللحظه خصوصا بعد
تصريح نائب رئيس التركي الذي قال وقبل
التصريح الانظار اتجهت لانه متى سيتوقف
عمليات الانقاذ ستتوقف هذه العمليات خصوصا
بعد ثمانيه ايام وتلاشي فرص بشكل كبير
العثور على ناجين الى نائب الرئيس التركي
صرح بان هذه العمليات ستستمر ما دام هنالك
فرصه لاظهار او استتات ناجين او حتى اخراج
ناجين مدام ان هنالك فرصه لاخراجهم احياء
فسيتم
عمليه رفع الانقاض وستستمر الى ان يتم
التاكد من ان كافه المباني لا توجد بها او
لا يوجد بها اشخاص احياء وايضا بالامكان
التوجه الى بعض او
الانتقال الى بعض
التكتيكات التي تم عملها اليوم هنا في
غازي عنتاب والنظر ربما الى عمليه رفع
الانقاذ بدات تقل تدريجيا او يتم توجيه
بعض الفرق الى مناطق ثانيه مثلا الفريق
السعودي للانقاذ تم توجيهه الى مدينه
انطاكيا وهو فعليا سيبدا بالعمل من
انطاكيا يوم غد وهو كان يعمل لمده اربعه
ايام في هذه المنطقه وبعد التنسيق مع
السلطات التركيه تم الاتفاق على اني ينتقل
فريق الانقاذ السعودي المكون من 100 شخص
وعدد من الاليات الى انطاكيا لهذا مؤشر
على ان عمليات الانقاذ لم تقل ولكن يتم
توجيه بعض الفرق الى المناطق الاكثر
احتياجا وهي تحدثت عن انطاكيا الخلافه
لذلك ايضا مشهد بدا ينتقل للبنيه التحتيه
خاصه في المناطق الاكثر تضررا والاحياء
الاكثر تضررا في غازي عنتاب كيف هو الوضع
فيها هل مثلا الكهرباء موجوده المياه
خطوط الاتصالات
نعم الكهرباء موجوده بشكل كبير ايضا
بالنسبه للانترنت والاتصالات ولكن المحل
لا تزال مغلقه بشكل كبير جدا المدينه يعني
شبه مهجوره من ناحيه حتى النشاط التجاري
لا يزال لا يعمل حتى هذه اللحظه بشكل
طبيعي عدد قليل من المحال تجولنا في شوارع
غازي عنتاب حيث شاهدنا عدد من كبير جدا من
المحال مغلق والمحل تحديدا المطاعم
المفتوحه لديها طوابير كبيره جدا من
الانتظار لنظرا لاغلاق كافه المطاعم
والاماكن التي تقدم الوجبات ايضا بالنسبه
لخطوط امداد الغاز التي تاثرت
بسبب هذا الزلزال وانقطعت المياه الدافئه
عن المدينه بشكل كامل لا تزال هذه المياه
لم تاتي بشكل كامل الى المدينه اجزاء من
المدينه لم يتم المياه الدافئه اليها
خصوصا مع هذه الدرجات الحراره المنخفضه
جدا نظرا لان هذه العمليه بدات بشكل
تدريجي بعض المناطق عادت اليها المياه
الدافئه والبعض الاخر لا يزال بدون مياه
دافئه حتى اللحظه بالاضافه الى ذلك لا
تزال عمليات تواجد النازحين في الشوارع
ملاحظه بشكل كبير
هو الصوره خلفيه في هذا الشارع الذي
يتواجد به عدد من النازحين في شارع عام
ليسوا في حديقه ولا في مكان مخصص للنازحين
ولكن يتواجدون في شارع عام وايضا البعض
منهم لا يزال ينام بالسيارات بالرغم من
المساعدات التي وصلت ولكن لم تستطع ان
توفي كل الاحتياجات سنعود اليك طبعا لانه
تغطيه العربيه ما زالت مستمره ولكن سانتقل
الان ايضا بعد قليل سننتقل لمتابعه
هذه الاوضاع في مختلف الولايات المتضرره
في تركيا وايضا الاوضاع في سوريا ولكن بعد
قليل اما الان سنتابع مما قاله وزير
الخارجيه السعودي الامير فيصل بن فرحان
بانه من المهم جدا تامين وصول المساعدات
الى المستحقيها في مناطق تركيا ومناطق
سوريا كافه
الكارثه التي حلت بكل من تركيا وسوريا
كبيره جدا وتقتضي توفير المساعدات
المناسبه المملكه ردت على الكارثه من خلال
ارسال المساعدات وفرق الاغاثه الى كلا
البلدين ونشجع الجميع على تقديم المساعدات
وفق ما تم بحثه في الاجتماع الثنائي مع
المندوب السامي السيد مرعب ومن المهم جدا
تامين وصول المساعدات الى مستحقيها في
تركيا وسوريا كافه يجب العمل على تخفيف
معاناه الشعب السوري ونبذل ما بوسعنا من
اجل وصول المساعدات الى المناطق كافه في
الداخل السوري
نتابع التغطيه ولكن الان مع زميل ليالي
الاختيار
[موسيقى]